Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
A lot of you been asking me questions
about Marvel's Thunderbolts movie
because the Sentry in that movie basically just quit.
So I'll explain what's going on.
A lot of people have been talking about the movie,
even though Marvel never officially announced
who was playing their Sentry, everybody
around the movie basically revealed what's going
on, notably Robert Kirkman, who is even associated
with the movie but is a good friend of Steven Yeun.
I'm so proud of that.
My good friend
Steven Yeun is playing this entry in a movie.
I saw that.
Yeah, I saw. That's that's coming up. That's.
It's going to be pretty exciting. Yeah. He called me.
He went in for a costume fitting.
I hope I'm not.
I don't think this is a spoiler or anything
that'll get anybody in trouble.
I don't know. Maybe we'll see.
I don't care for marble.
They're going to do to me more, he said.
He said I just came back from a costume
fitting for the Sentry.
I guess I only do superheroes that are yellow and blue.
He said he
was at the costume fitting and was like, crap,
I forgot. Invincible was yellow and blue.
the way he just does not give an F like
he does not care at all.
What's Marvel going to do to me?
the funny answer to that is that Disney
would probably try to sue him out of existence.
But he's rich. He has plenty of lawyers.
I don't think he's in any trouble But if you're brand
new to the channel, be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos,
all explained what's going on with the actual movie.
The movie itself isn't changing that much.
They're going to recast the Sentry,
so it'll be a completely different actor.
But the main story is going to be the same most of you
probably saw in your piece.
Steven Yeun issued a statement
about quitting the Thunderbolts movie.
He was very apologetic,
said that he wanted to do a marvel movie
at some point, so he probably had to come back
as some completely different character.
Now, maybe Amadeus know there are a lot of ideas
you could throw out there, but essentially
they're getting ready to film the Thunderbolts movie.
But because there were so many delays because of the
strikes last year, he basically had to quit the movie.
It had nothing to do with the actual script
or the quality of the movie or anything like that.
so it wasn't him quitting for dubious reasons,
if you weren't aware the reason why Robert Kirkman
was talking about Steven Yeun as the Sentry
talking about Omni-Man in the invincible character
is because Steven Yeun plays
Invincible on the Invincible series.
It's fantastic.
probably one of the best superhero related series
next to the boys that are on TV right now.
the funny thing is
they're actually making a live action invincible movie.
now. Because Steven Yeun quit the movie.
He could actually do that live action.
Invincible movie, even though I think they want to go
with a slightly younger version of the character
in live action,
originally the reason why Jake Schreier Marvel cast him
as Sentry in the movie is because of his work with him
on the Beef series that he just did before.
The Thunderbolts movie is a great series
if you haven't seen it.
It's like the slow descent of a couple humans
after they get into a minor fender bender
with their mental health getting worse and worse, then
getting crazier and crazier
and just doing worse and worse things.
And there's kind of like a speed run version of that
during the Thunderbolts movie,
is basically Marvel's
version of the Suicide Squad movie
even though they probably don't want
that comparison made just because it makes it seem too
similar to DC's Dick James Gunn's suicide Squad movie.
ba. Basically that's the set up you have Val,
who's like their version of Amanda Waller,
putting the team together to fix a mess
that she herself created when she created the Sentry.
And he went crazy, turning into the void,
making him the most dangerous person on the planet.
Like you basically kill
someone who could wipe the entire planet.
know.
You have to put a team of anti-heroes together
who nobody cares about.
You don't care if they die,
so they're expendable to try and clean up your mess.
currently the Thunderbolts team is Winter Soldier.
Red Guardian. Yelena Belova, Black Widow, U.S.
Agent Ghost
Taskmaster in Aota Berry is playing Val's assistant.
Most of you remember her from the Bear.
She's a great actress.
They usually use her in comedic things, like darkly
comedic things you can definitely picture her
without like trying to deal with Val
but essentially the idea in the movie is
that Val has taken over control of the weapons
plus program and that's where the Sentry comes from.
This is the clip of the director talking about what
the movie is actually about characters.
And is there something specific to those characters
that bring them together
and something that they're going through that is,
you know,
the most traditional superhero story to be told?
And I think that's sort of similar to the way
that we're looking at thunderbolts.
But there is a real clear take
and perspective on these characters,
and there's a specificity to it
And then also, you know, John Waters,
my roommate from college, and we're good friends.
And so knowing this, what a great experience
he had making those films.
and I even did unit on like the L.A.
portion of one of the Spider-Man movies.
So like having a little bit
more kind of connection or insight into that world.
But beyond that, it was just
like a really different approach
and a new kind of story to tell.
And there were so many things,
but it is, you know, it's not a sequel
and it's not, you know, yes, these characters
have appeared before, but it is a new story being told
and a story, I think, with a very different perspective
than maybe people are expecting.
And I think that that felt exciting
and felt like a real challenge worth taking on.
Sentry's real name is Robert Reynolds.
He started out as a drug addict
who was just down on his luck and broke into a lab
where he thought he could find a score.
He took what he thought was going to be drugs
that were going to get him high,
but it wound up giving him powers.
It wound up being the golden sentry serum,
which was a derivative
of the super soldier serum, part of the weapons
Plus program.
it gave him the power of a million.
Exploding suns like that version of the super soldier
serum was way more potent than the version
that the other super soldiers on the Thunderbolts
team got, or even Captain America got.
but the process of getting all that power
when he was already kind of broken mentally
caused him to develop an alternate personality called
the Void, who's a totally evil version of himself
with an equal level of power,
but different types of powers
so a lot of his backstory
is similar to the backstory for Homelander
and the other boys superhero characters
getting their powers from Compound V
but the whole picture is is he's mentally very broken
character he's not mentally stable.
So the whole idea is
what if Superman but he's totally crazy,
which is where you get to the Sentry in the MCU.
totally schizophrenic.
He's a schizo type of personality disorder.
Not the same thing that Moon Knight suffered from,
but similar.
Both of them have alternate personalities
like Moon Knight has Marc Spector.
Steven Grant We just meet Jake Lockley
at the end of that series, but he has something
called dissociative identity disorder,
which is different from what Sentry has
Soldier Boy is a good example.
Like he's the first version of the compound.
These superheroes that they created.
Eventually they refined the formula like they did
for the Sentry in Homelander.
It winds up getting a much more potent version of it,
becoming nine invulnerable,
the most powerful person on planet Earth.
but the whole picture is is he's mentally very broken
character he's not mentally stable.
So the whole idea is what if Superman
but he's totally crazy,
which is where you get to the Sentry in the MCU.
they revealed what's going on with Val
Thunderbolt Ross and their whole plot
to recreate super soldiers in the Weapons Plus program.
This pays off a long running Easter egg
that I'll explain in the second
from the first Incredible Hulk movie.
in it, D23.
Kevin Feige very specifically remarked
that Winter Soldier was going
to be the most mentally stable person
on the Thunderbolts.
David Harbor, who plays Red Guardian.
So said, it's all about this group of fundamentally
broken people.
Mentally broken, that is.
Who have crazy levels of powers.
Who find a way to work together and help
heal each other slowly, like, help
each other actually accomplish their mission,
but also fix a lot of their mental problems.
They've been suffering from in a lot of them
just happen to be super soldiers.
Kind of like Sentry is.
Technically, he's a super soldier, even though it's
a slightly different version of the formula.
through Captain America four In the Thunderbolts movie,
they're paying off this long running Easter Egg
from the Incredible Hulk movie with the Weapons
Plus program, which is meant to be Thunderbolt,
Ross's renamed version of the Super Soldier program.
So, for example, Wolverine
comes from the Weapon X program,
but X is a Roman numeral that stands for ten.
He's the 10th version of the weapons
plus program of them trying to recreate a super soldier
using different means.
all the members of the team
here come from some iteration of the weapons
plus program or some offshoot in the case of the Winter
Soldier with Hydra's Winter Soldier program.
so the idea in the movie is the Sentry has gone crazy
and the thunderbolts have to come in and stop him.
Probably kill him on Val's orders.
they're couple of changes they made to the way
that the Sentry's powers worked too.
So instead of him
just transforming into the, like, the void personality,
taking over his body in him
having some kind of physical transformation and off.
First off, his powers are going to work a little bit
like Dragon Ball, Super Saiyan transformations
when he transforms into just regular sentry
instead of his body transforming.
When the void takes over his mind,
it'll actually be more like the jujutsu kaisen domain
expansion ability, where the thunderbolts literally
have to travel into his domain like his mindspace,
lot of anime tropes working into Marvel nowadays,
but Jujutsu Kaisen has been so fired
that if you're going to borrow from something in anime,
that would be the right place to do it.
even though Steven Yeun is leaving the project,
I'm expecting most of the story
to say the same as it was before
because they are getting ready to shoot.
But Because so much time has gone by.
Since they announced the Thunderbolts movie,
they might have changed a little bit of it.
Also, with all the delays generally nowadays, Vallance
seems kind of like their Nick Fury in that
she shows up in everybody's post-credits scenes.
Who's kind of filming that role?
We might see her in a couple of post-credits
scenes in the upcoming movies
because there's a lot of ground level stuff
happening during Marvel Phase five just in general.
In fact, speaking of ground level,
the people who made Echo in are making Daredevil
born again so that they're actually setting up kingpin
to be their ground level Thanos inside the MCU.
So a lot of hope for him showing up in Spider-Man
four is one of the big antagonists.
all these separate videos about Spider-Man four.
When we get more details about that,
that's like a whole completely separate thing.
Let me know in the comments Is the Sentry
roll is wide open Now.
Who do you want to actually play that character?
and if you haven't seen them.
I did videos for all the Invincible episodes.
They're amazing.
So I'll post links for those in the description below.
We're going to get the second half of Invincible Season
2 later this year.
click here for that
brand new Daredevil trailer with all of Marvel's
Netflix defenders
now being Cannon to the MCU confirmed.
Thankfully, Marvel finally confirmed that.
and click here for that
brand new Marvel Moon Knight Season 2 announcement
Thank you so much for watching
Happy New Year and I'll see you guys in the next one!